each of your hands has five bones called
metacarpals between your wrist and your
fingers
at the base of your thumb the first
metacarpal forms a joint with a bone in
your wrist called the trapezium
smooth tissue called cartilage covers
the ends of the bones in the joint
cartilage cushions the joint
it also allows your bones to move easily
when you swivel
pivot
or grip things with your thumb
osteoarthritis of the thumb also known
as basal thumb arthritis is a condition
where the cartilage in this joint breaks
down and wears
away without cartilage your bones rub
together which can damage your joint
over time bony growths called bone spurs
can form in and around your joint
you may have a higher risk for getting
thumb osteoarthritis if you're female
you've had previous injury to the joint
such as a fracture
or if you have an unstable loose
ligament in the joint
common symptoms of thumb osteoarthritis
include
bony bumps on the joint
joint pain and swelling
and loss of joint motion and grip
strength
if you have questions about thumb
osteoarthritis talk to your health care
provider
this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or enmol
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
you